とっ
今日じゃんっ
ああ
始め雪よね皆さんお願いシャープペンでガード
ご存知でしょうかシャーペンマニアなら僕も果たし紹介したことがあると思うんです
けども
ka 先のここが丈夫でですね俺ないという意味でデルガード
ウエア斜めから強く押しても出れガード知ってるより芯をしっかりガードしてくれると
いうシャーペン
ここが全然は折れにくいですつまり筆圧の強い人とか
書くときにやると死んだし硬いのでシャー芯が折れることがないという仕組みになって
おります僕も結構筆圧が強いのでデーターのすごい
役立ちます今回でちょっと何かご縁があってかわかりませんがから出るガードをつくっ
ている改善はゼブラさんから
終わる箱が届きました
と釣られあいてるのバレちゃっとずれずこれが届きましたちょっと開けていきましょう
何言っ
数頭ですんおおゼブラさんが手紙が届きました
緊急依頼肇社長様背景 web だモデルが竿れない車
ナンバーワンを目指していますここにジェラートとサイコロをお送りいたします
サイコロを振って出た本数を使ってぜひ
俺9を実証してください今回は語文のユーチューバー様に往復路しています
皆様の楽しい動画を期待しています敬具ゼブラ株式会社
なるほどなるほどやります
3便は好きなのでこういうのをしっかりやっておいた方が今後のためになる
拝殿で最高のかこちらになります本1本100本
50本がいろいろなんですけどもまぁ500
さて放ってみてください頃振って出た保温性の出るカードで競る形が折れないという
ことを証明すればミッションクリアというわけですよね
[ __ ]じゃこの体裁はじめ様か彼はそんな共有さ
ていきましょうでたらめの本数使ってきますからおっいよいよ
いいんじゃないかと思いますうわぁわぁわあ
はもう
んうわーうわーうわーうわーううーーがーっ
パイプ500本ですうーん
動画的にはおいしい入って来て5年ポンドてるカードを使ってこれが折れないという
ことを証明していきましょう本当に500本中は絶対入ってる
ゼブラさんマジっすかうーんすごいとこれ嬉しいわー
じゃあマニアとしては非常にうれしいんですけども
jena はいという木で作らさんから出る数500本
いただきましたポスト3アスパラ買ったなわかりましたそのデリなど500本を使って
僕が出るガードが折れないということを証明してみせましょう
今からベレガード500本使って橋を作りますその価値を作るんですけどその橋の
ブリッジ部分がしっかりとモデルがのススメ
しっかりされててどう
これがはたくても折れなかったらもうでる方最強です
1持っても折れないってことは常会で折れることはないんですからそれでちょっと証明
してみせましょう
第5位とりあえずこの机2つ使います
ほら今机の下からゼブラさんのボールペンが出てきました
ゼブラ愛用者です
ok こんな感じでこの間に箸を作りますでは要するにこの身の部分でその橋を支えれ
ばいいのでこういう感じですここでしっかりできればいいと思ってるんで
この間別にデザートしなくてもいいと思ってるんで鉄パイプを使いますこの撤廃富士山
でるかと思うほぼサイズがぴったりでこういう感じでさっきだけが出るようになります
これより8
サイドに入れていい感じに
こんな感じじゃないですかこれはちゃんと0g の神殿を持ってますここにそいじゃあ
もう
a もこれ着た完全に来たジャンこういう感じでレザード筒の先端を使ってくれず橋の
元となる部分をつくっていきましょう
配球で橋のベースは完成しましたこれ全部でガードの質の部分だけで支えております
もうこの時点で結構感動してるんですけど問題はここからですこれをしっかりとした
ハッシュにしていくために僕が歩くところを登りの出るカードで作っていきましょう
さあ
何しました
ああああああ
はぁった円高 od
はいというを入れて完成しましたいやあの混ぜ大変だったからねはいで小柄なんです
けどもこのデルガード
疹が出てない状態でさんの福井城すると折れてしまう可能性があるらしい
中で写真を出すときはミノックじゃないかなっとしたら非常にゾーブで折れないらしい
です
ということで本当にでレガートからで写真は折れないのかという検証したいのでこっち
が技
では写真で橋を支えてもらいますこっちはそのままこの2の方で支えてもらいます
こっちサイドは写真ねされるのでこっちサイドがいかに
僕が取ったときに折れるか折れないかがポイントになりますではちょっと支援を出して
いきましょう
はいだけで完成しましたシャーペン500本でガードで作った走ってガードしば本当に
折れないとかどうか橋な女を渡って検証してみようと思いますいきます
もうヤラセなしですよ一発勝負ですもう企業アンケートの関係なしもう本当に俺はもう
出る穴を信じるしかないですよ
ではベルがばこんなに俺のか検証
していこうと思います
います
つい
ああああああ
ええええええ
web
はいおれましたまあまあこればかりは仕方ないに箸をつくってしまうとまぁデルガード
が悪いというか神と僕の作り方の問題だったコースんですね
ということで出るだろ僕とが筆圧の強い方にはとても強い武器になると思います
もう金が出かけますからね正しい使い方をすればまずをれることはないのでぜひよかっ
たら使ってみてください
本会ですね僕以外のユーチューバーモデルカードの強化を挙げております私弾みシャツ
をそして pictures
満田のリボンドアバンピーズとミックさんとして bon tv を動画を上げており
ますよかったらそちらもチェックしてみてください
あの
正しく使わねー
じゃ